roger prieuré journalistes amis et
supporteurs de gaston defferre un
supporter qui je l'espère sera préservé
sa liberté de jugement mais il faut
d'abord que nous vous disions que nous
vous mettons en présence d'une
présentation exceptionnelle très
différente de celle de tous les autres
candidats
vous avez devant vous à la fois le
candidat lui-même gaston defferre et son
éventuel premier ministre pierre
mendès-france gaston defferre député
maire de marseille ancien ministre et
pierre mendès-france dont je dirai pas
ce que c'est à la mode qu'il a eu déjà
et qu'il est appelé à avoir encore un
grand destin national
gaston defferre ce mode de présentation
a été déjà très critiqué par les autres
candidats
oui il était critiqué par eux et la même
donné lieu à des polémiques n'ont pas de
caractère personnel mais de caractère
politique
je tiens à répondre mais d'abord
répondre sur le fond
la constitution prévoit en effet que
c'est le gouvernement qui conduit la
politique de la nation le président de
la république qui est un arbitre et
depuis qu'il est élu au suffrage
universel
il est le garant des grandes options
politiques qui ont été faites par
l'ensemble des électeurs si bien que en
nous présentant ensemble pierre
mendès-france et moi même devant les
électeurs nous pouvons définir d'une
part des grandes options du candidat à
la présidence de la république et
d'autre part et c'est très important
étant de gravité de la situation
économique sociale financière monétaire
à laquelle nous nous trouvons nous
pouvons définir le programme et ses
pierres mais je pense qu'il le fera du
gouvernement car cela intéresse les
français
demain des élections que va-t-on faire
quelle politique va t'on appliquée c'est
une question capitale pour vous tous et
pour toutes qui nous écouter eh bien il
faut que vous le sachiez
c'est parce que nous avons voulu que
cette campagne se déroule en toute
clarté que nous avons décidé l'un et
l'autre de le présenter de cette façon
devant vous ainsi rien ne sera laissé
dans l'ombre et au lendemain des
élections on ne peut pas valve
impression d'avoir été trompés oui mais
il ya quelque chose de très important
dans cet accord entre le candidat et son
premier ministre
réfléchissez à ce qui est en train de se
passer ceux d'entre vous qui lisent
attentivement les journaux le savent
monsieur poher président intérimaire et
monsieur ou de murville ont engagé une
guerre de communiqués cette guerre de
communiqués vous voulez part ni à
l'avancé il serait sain que les autres
candidats en piste autant oui mais ils
peuvent pas le faire car et c'est là que
le bât blesse car s'il le faisait il
risquerait de mécontenter certains de
leurs amis et donc une partie de leur
électorat ans nous avons parfaitement
que si monsieur pompidou si monsieur
frère de zine tel ou tel premier
ministre ce ne sera pas la même
politique qui sera fait si bien que
suivant le choix du premier ministre
c'est une politique ou une autre qui
sera faite par le gouvernement et que
vous qui est directement concerné par
cela vous qui nous écoute et vous en
subirez les conséquences
c'est la première chose nous ont à faire
d'ailleurs pierre mendès-france et moi
c'est le bilan
l'inventaire pour savoir où on en est et
à cet égard je dois dire que l'actuel
gouvernement et le candidat
gouvernementales ont de très lourdes et
de très graves responsabilités
ce bilan sera une chose très importante
et avant de vous demander que la note
dominante de votre campagne
je voudrais que nos téléspectateurs
comprennent très bien l'importance qu'il
ya à avoir choisi pour deux fonctions
qui sont content
commentaire est tout de même différente
deux hommes deux tempéraments et de
caractère aussi différents que tous les
deux car les tâches ne sont pas sont à
la fois associés est différente puisque
le président de la république
un rôle qui est distinct de celui de
premier ministre mais je vous demande
gaston defferre
qu'est ce qui vous ferait le plus
important tout de suite à faire dès que
16 juin rien j'aurais dit d'abord le
bilan ensuite déterminer les
responsables et puis mettre en oeuvre
immédiatement une politique pour faire
face à la situation
sinon la situation monétaire financière
dans laquelle se trouve notre pays
responsables nous connaissons est le
principal d'entre eux celui qui a eu la
charge l'intendance pendant plus de six
ans rappelons le par son nom c'est
monsieur georges pompidou au bien je
sais qu'aujourd'hui il promet tout il
oublié ce qu'il a fait il renie son
passé et demain si nous n'en croyons
il y aura moins d'impôts plus de
logements plus d'hôpitaux d'écoles de
lycées de facultés mêmes dit il
ce téléphone fonctionnera bien je veux
dire que quand on entend cela il ya lieu
de sourire car est ce que vous vous
rappelez en 1957 un grand hebdomadaire
avait fait faire une enquête pour savoir
quelles étaient les services publics qui
fonctionnait le mieux ou le plus mal en
france ou moins mal en france or on en
avait conclu que c'était le téléphone
qui fonctionne elle me oui ce que ces
messieurs n'ont fait et puis il m'a
exposé à vous le dire
sur le plan de l'économie en général ils
ont poussé notre pays
ils l'ont acculé presque à la voie du
sous-développement par rapport à nos
partenaires du marché commun je ne parle
pas bien sûr des grandes nations de très
grandes nations qui elles ont pris sur
nous une avance considérable
ils ont donc une très lourde
responsabilité
il s'agit de savoir maintenant comment
nous allons pouvoir sortir de la
situation dans laquelle ils nous ont
placés avant cela je voudrais que pirmin
despres
on nous précise bien sa pensée sur ce
problème qui est le plus chaud en 1969
celui de la possible dévaluation du
franc ah oui on parle beaucoup de
dévaluation parle beaucoup de la monnaie
alors je voudrais tout de même ici dire
quelque chose qu'ils doivent payer mes
yeux est très important la monnaie n'est
qu'un reflet n'est qu'une traduction
d'une situation en profondeur situation
de l'économie situation de la production
industrielle agricole etc
si tout cela se porte bien la monnaie se
porte bien
si tout cela est mal gérée c'est la
monnaie qui en subit les conséquences et
la monnaie c'est le pouvoir d'achat et
par conséquent l'ensemble des français
en ressentent les effets alors il faut
que nous ayons conscience puisque nous
allons faire un choix important pour les
années qui viennent
il faut que nous ayons conscience de ce
qu'a été le bilan des années écoulées au
point de vue économique
au point de vue de la production à cet
égard hélas le bilan est mauvais si vous
regardez ce qui se passe par exemple
l'intérieur des pays du marché commun
vous constatez que la france est celui
de ces pays où les salaires ont augmenté
le plus lentement les salaires cost en
monnaies constantes et serré alors que
le prix de la ville a augmenté plus vite
et le druide la vie a augmenté plus vite
que chez nos partenaires par conséquent
ce salaire augmentant moins vite prix
augmentant plus vite pouvoir d'achat
évidemment niveau de vie évidemment à
terme c'est la même chose d'ailleurs
dans beaucoup d'autres domaines peu
parlé du logement savez vous que dans
les quatre dernières années le
gouvernement actuel n'a pas été capable
les gouvernements n'ont pas été capables
de décoller du niveau très insuffisant
de la construction de logements qu'ils
s'agissent des logements mis en chantier
ou qu'il s'agisse des logements achevés
depuis quatre ans nous sommes nous nous
sommes dans la stagnation nous
n'avançons pas et je pense que cela
aussi c'est un fait important de
personnes ne devraient oublier ya le
problème de l'emploi
il ya un peu moins de chômage
aujourd'hui qu'il ya un an tout à
l'heure je dirais peut-être pourquoi
mais nous savons bien combien ce
problème reste préoccupant et
spécialement pour les hommes qui ont
atteint certaines âge et peut-être plus
encore pour les jeunes qui commencent
leur carrière professionnelle et qui ne
sont pas très sûrs de trouver du travail
et bien quand on pense que le niveau de
ville pouvoir d'achat ainsi stagné
depuis des années je dis qu'il ne
devrait pas y avoir un salarié en france
qui votent pour les hommes qui sont
responsables de cela quand on pense au
piétinement du logement de la
construction je dis qu'il n'ya pas un
mal logés en france qui devraient voter
pour ceux qui sont responsables de cela
quand on parle de l'emploi jeudi qu'il
n'y a pas un jeune en france à la
recherche de travail qui devraient voter
demain pour les hommes qui sont
responsables de cela
or je sais bien vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure de faire monsieur pompidou nous
annonce que tout va changer que demain
il fera le contraire de ce qu'il a fait
hier mais ce qu'il a fait hier nous
continuons à subir des effets et le
premier effet c'est ici que je réponds à
la question de prix y aurait le premier
effet c'est l'effet monétaire parce que
cette lenteur économique sous-emploi ce
piétinement
cette insuffisance de dynamisme
industriel cette insuffisance de
compétitivité dans tous les domaines et
bien c'est naturellement la monnaie qui
en subit les effets c'est à dire le
pouvoir d'achat de tous les français
la monnaie ce n'est pas un stock d'or
stérile fugitif qui entre et qui sort
c'était peut-être vrai au moyen âge
lorsque les gouvernements en assez de
stock d'or dans leur forteresse
aujourd'hui la monnaie c'est la richesse
collective c'est la production celle
dynamisme c'est la capacité d'aller de
l'avant et d'améliorer le sort de tous
les hommes qui vivent et qui travaillent
et bien aujourd'hui dans ce domaine
hélas nous subissons les conséquences
d'une mauvaise gestion et c'est à cette
mauvaise gestion que les français
doivent mettre un terme pour adopter des
solutions positives celle qu'au cours de
la campagne électorale
nous allons définir ensemble et c'est un
fait que ce biais de différents volets
francs 60 bis à genève aujourd'hui et ce
sera votre problème de départ
et avant de donner rendez-vous à mardi
20h aux téléspectateurs je demanderai à
gaston defferre de tirer la première
conclusion de cette entrevue très brève
entre nous et c'est maintenant à vous
tous et vous tout qui nous écoutent et
que je veux m'adresser
ce qui est en cause sont vos conditions
d'existence c'est votre niveau de vie et
cela dépendra des solutions qui sont
adoptés solution de caractère
conservateur qui consisteront à
maintenir les choses telles qu'elles
sont ou au contraire solutions
novatrices de caractère socialiste
ce socialisme moderne qui veut
transformer la société la faire
progresser et de les racheter à tous des
chances égales dans l'existence
[Musique]